foreign
David is up in Columbus Ohio David how
can we help
hello hello
what's going on
well my wife and I went to the Financial
Peace University DVD set last year and
it helped us to pay off quite a large
amount of debt from our credit cards and
a personal loan that I had and um we've
worked ourselves down to two deaths but
we seem to be stuck in a revolving door
of the baby steps the past six months
and
um kind of looking for guidance on where
to go from here okay what's this
revolving door have you had some
emergencies
yeah we built up our emergency fund
we've got three vehicles one of them I
owe on the other two we own outright the
two that we do own on have some higher
miles so every time we build up the fund
they need maintenance or the house needs
maintenance
um we build up our six months uh
essentially savings and unfortunately
last year we had an unexpected need to
put a roof on the house so that took a
big chunk out of that fund as well
um so we're kind of looking where to get
it from here I'd like to put more on my
401k
how much are you put in now
and I was putting 15 in uh last year I
cut it back to six percent to help pay
off the excess debt and I'm wanting to
take that back to 15. but I'm torn as to
whether to put more into 401k or to pay
off the car when I'm going to currently
have I'm confused as to which Financial
Peace University you went through David
you're doing 17 things at once yes
that's that's our our downfall we seem
to take on way too much at once okay so
how about this what if for six months
you tried the plan as is and you went
all in which means we're not investing
we're taking our savings down to a
thousand dollars and we're putting every
single ounce of energy and money towards
our Consumer Debt
would you would you take that challenge
absolutely and I tell you that because I
have such confidence in you and I've
seen thousands of people who go all in
actually accomplish it and I've also
talked to hundreds more on the phones
who go hey I don't know why I'm not
making the progress I should be and also
I'm not following the baby steps as is
and so it's not to be fundamentalist
it's just to go when you focus all of
your energy and intensity on one thing
at a time you make progress that's all
it is so how much do you have left in
Consumer Debt
we owe a hundred thousand on our house
and we owe 13 well I owe 13 000 on my
car so we're just 13 away from this
thing being done in baby step two
correct what's the car worth
uh it books for right under 14 however
the offers I've gotten from the dealer
I've tried to sell back to them um
they're not winning the budge off of 10.
well forget the dealers let's go private
party let's do our research online and
see if there's any online companies that
would buy it for more and uh go from
there because this clears the deck for
you to be able to start saving up that
fully funded emergency fund and you have
three cars do you need can you survive
on with two
uh yeah we're exploring the option of
selling our truck we own an outright so
that would be you know sixty five
hundred to seven thousand dollars we
could pocket okay and I I don't want to
miss David I want you to miss what
George said you're kind of like yeah
don't sell the car to the dealer they're
never going to give you what you can get
private parties it's not even close
yeah I I tried to sell a private party
last month unfortunately you know a lot
of Tire kickers not a whole lot of
interest and they seem to offer about
the same as where'd you list it Where'd
you post it well he was listening on
Craigslist local ads Facebook
um just a couple places well are you
offering are you selling it for what it
would it really could command via Blue
Book
oh yeah the new books uh listed it for
13.9 I had it priced just under 14.
um I even had a couple offers out you
know that someone was willing to do 13-5
essentially that would dissolve the loan
and I'd pocket 400 and I could wash my
hands of it and continue on the phone
why didn't you do that
uh the best offer I could get was around
10. oh you weren't actually getting
those Oh I thought you said yeah yeah
that's the downside what's your
household income David
uh we bring in we gross about 100 a year
okay so let's say we even didn't sell
the car how quickly do you think this
thing's getting paid off if we brought
investing down to zero and we want full
focus on getting rid of this car loan
um
I know without touching the investing we
calculated we could potentially have it
paid off by August uh without the
investing I'd say I'm thinking 90 days
max
you guys are bringing up I mean you're
bringing home what 7K a month
um a little bit under that
so 13 let's say we could divide that in
three right
that's going to be 4 300 bucks a month
so the question now becomes how do we
find forty three hundred dollars worth
of margin to throw at this debt which
means we're pausing investing which
means we're not eating out which means
we're hatching you know getting the the
budget dialed in could you come up with
four grand a month to throw out this car
alone
absolutely
and so now 90 days from now we're at
baby step three and so we're out of this
vicious cycle you've been experiencing
and if there was another emergency we
would just pause the baby steps and
start saving up with those future
paychecks
okay
but you got to go all in for this to
work David and so I want you to call us
back as you go all in on this and let us
know if anything has changed for you
because I think it will